face aux parlementaires israéliens le
discours est musclé
violence qui leur demande d'adopter une
position plus ferme contre la russie
plus tard dans la nuit via le canal
télégramme le président ukrainien
demande à son homologue israélien d'être
le médiateur de cette guerre
le premier ministre israélien naftali
bennet essaye de trouver un chemin pour
la négociation avec la russie et nous
lui en sommes reconnaissants pour tous
ses efforts afin que tôt ou tard nous
puissions commencer la discussion avec
la russie peut-être âgées russes c'est
le bon endroit pour trouver la paix
c'est possible
la tâche est alléchante pour naftali
bennet l'état hébreu par lot de caen et
entretient de bonnes relations avec les
belligérants la tentative de médiation a
d'ailleurs commencé début mars à moins
de 15 jours après le début de la guerre
samedi 5 mars
naftali bennet s'envolaite en plein
shabbat pour moscou un entretien de
trois heures avec vladimir poutine dont
rien n'a filtré c'était la première
visite en russie d'un dirigeant étranger
pour parler de l'invasion russe le même
jour le premier ministre israélien a
appelé le président ukrainien
mais dans ce conflit israël marche sur
des oeufs d'un côté il ya cette alliance
historique avec les états unis fervent
soutien de l'ukraine
de l'autre il ya les contraintes
géostratégique qui oblige l'état hébreu
a gardé une certaine proximité avec
moscou à sa frontière nord il y à la
syrie où les russes sont très présents
en cas de brouiller avec israël il
serait donc facile pour le président
russe de perturber les équilibres
fragiles de la région en s'appuyant
notamment sur le mouvement chiite
hezbollah sur le dossier ukrainien donc
l'état hébreu joue les équilibristes
condamné la russie sans infliger de
sanction à moscou ait refusé de vendre
des armes à kiev qui a pourtant réclamé
plusieurs fois déjà le dôme de fer le
système de défense aérien israélien